we've got some good news for you finally
after this long litany of sadness your
smartphone about to get a major and we
think important update
a new emoji a pregnant man emoji
reportedly set to debut
in your text messages very soon you can
see the pregnant man now
looking more constipated than pregnant
but who are we to judge
we're not doctors chief mark stein is in
a sense a doctor he's our chief emoji
correspondent he's here on set
for his uh for his assessment
um so mark stein a pregnant man no
pregnant men don't exist in nature but
they now exist on your phone
is this good or bad yeah i actually i
think that emoji
is of uh prince harry who i gather
he's about three months gone as i
understand he's having a big problem
with morning sickness
uh he he as you see it's his hair color
uh he shaved off the beard but he kept
the porn star moustache
because megan told him she could get him
a
bit part in something that's filming in
the san fernando valley so
uh that's uh that's yeah that's prince
harry the pregnant man he's the first
member of the royal family
uh to be an emoji while pregnant so i
think that actually
that when you were mocking his
commitment to diversity i think taking
one for the team like that
uh speaks very highly for him it's just
so weird
you know you wake up one morning and and
everything seems fine and then you learn
that ron jeremy is pregnant and has an
english accent
it's living in yeah exactly exactly
it's all it's all up for grabs it is
definitely up for grabs
um under what circumstances would you
use this emoji in your personal text
messages well that's what i don't
get because an emoji is supposed to be
you know jazz
wow or it's uh you know tears of joy i
don't understand in what way the
pregnant man i don't
oh it's my uh 25th wedding anniversary
party on saturday i hope you're going to
come
uh how does the uh pregnant man emoji
assist you with that i don't understand
the circumstance maybe we're missing the
point
maybe it's when someone says something
like completely ludicrous
you just respond with a pregnancy you
think that's insane here's a pregnant
man well to me i mean to make a
semi-serious point i think
emojis which i don't personally use i
don't either um
but i think they're actually the h.g
wells thing when
he said in the time machine and he got
in the time machine went into the future
and he found that people's language had
devolved to a few
primitive catchphrases i think the emoji
is the stage that follows that and the
pregnant man emoji is the stage that
follows
the original emojis because it's got
it's got nothing to do with anything
except
look i'm cool with the idea of the
pregnant man of course
yeah you know i'm not sure it should
have been prince harry to be the pioneer
of this
but uh but you know i mean favorite
pregnant men
generally if you prefer to have pregnant
women there are still like one or two
out there but basically
it's all going to be pregnant men and uh
and if
and uh if you object to that you're just
an uptight square
and you need to get with the program
that's that's the purpose of
it you're an uptight square and you need
to get with the program that's the main
purpose
of the pregnant man emoji i'm gonna send
that emoji
in every text i send every day until
they ban me from texting
yeah absolutely and that and it'll
become the most popular i think it's
actually also
uh on a stamp in canada because it is
obviously a member of the royal family
uh who's the first pregnant
male there so that's as you're talking
i'm thinking to myself
i could listen to this for an hour and
we're about to take
an hour uh on our fox nation
yeah seriously the full hour on harry
and megan
otherwise ladies and gentlemen markstein
great to see you thanks a lot thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else